e
[Silence]
albar abbar
allahar ill
[Silence]
m for
allahar
[Silence]
alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah for
[Silence]
sub
my dear brothers respected Elders we
thank Allah subhana tala for keeping us
alive one more day on the path of Islam
on theim and allowing me and you to
enter his house and worship him in the
manner that pleases him I ask Allah subh
accept from me and accept from you the
little we do in his path am mean and I
bear witness there is no DED worthy of
worship except for Allah subhana tala
and Prophet Muhammad sallallah alai
wasam is his last and fin messenger for
surely who Allah subhana tala chooses to
guide n and misguide and you were choose
to misguide n can guide him back to the
path and we seek refuge in Allah from
darkness of ourselves and evil of our
Deeds for Allah is all knowing and all
seeing what his creation
does if you have spent enough time at
mcct then you're probably aware
the after Thanksgiving is dedicated to a
particular
purpose and that particular purpose is
to Enlighten and highlight for the
Muslim
communities particularly here and we
hope that inshallah that message can be
transmitted through people who are
attending here and people who watch it
online is that this
idea that most of us in America through
assimilation have
accepted this idea of
Thanksgiving this idea of that there was
nothing in the
Americas when the white man came to to
the shores
and that people here were
Savages they had no culture or
lifestyle and they had no ways or
means and that could be the furthest
that is the furthest things not could be
that is the furthest thing from the
truth and as such it is our
responsibility to educate and Enlighten
our people and our children and our
youth today so we can have better
understand understanding of
what was the truth what was happening
and why are we here the way we are here
today first and
foremost understanding that the idea
that has been passed around today around
that it was a
communal dinner and people were sitting
and celebrating that probably is not
true through historical facts
probably on the first time around that
probably was truthful because when these
people did come to the shores they had
no idea what to do how to harvest how to
to to Source food because they were not
from this land they were not accustomed
to Lo local culture and local ways so
the natives did help
them but that probably was it because
once they were settled in it was a fight
for the
resources and then killing and pillaging
starts and these people are then kicked
off their own land for the colonial
settlers who come
in and by the way the the white men knew
well that they were not
Indians and I've said this before the
Columbus knew all well where he was
traveling to
because he sailed from the port of dolba
in Spain which was used by the Muslims
thousands years thousands or 600 years
plus before him Muslims had already
traveled to to the to the
Americas the map already existed and you
can Google this up you know I'm not here
spewing a story to make Feelgood story
about Muslim lives the perior map that
was that was a kartographer it was a
famous Turkish Admiral who had a map and
the map is available online you can go
look it up Google it download it
whatever and they shows the the the shes
of Americas on
it so he knew Fair well where he was
going but it was a good narrative to fit
in in in the story but we just happened
to come
here we just happened to found find a
piece of land in the middle of nowhere
there was nobody around on
it the natives had a healthy population
before the white came to the
shore they thrived the land
thrived but the narrative does not
fit I ask you a simple question today
you go outside you step outside the
Masjid you can find Chinese food you can
find American fast food you can find
Korean food you can find Thai food you
can find Indian food what is the native
food what stores living in Tucson living
in Arizona by the way which is the most
densely
packed tribal land meaning there's more
tribes that are federally recognized
that are in Arizona than any other state
in the United States of America where is
the native food
stores what restaurant have you gone to
that has native food that served and
before you come and tell me after the
Salah oh she they have Fred bread fried
bread is not Native Food
bro it's
not native folks did not eat fried stuff
they
forged they cooked fried bread comes out
of the settler Colonial mindset when the
US government the US the colonists
themselves forced the natives not to
hunt bison not to you know do fishing
for salmon when they block them from all
of those things and they put them in
camps they made them March from the East
Coast all all the way to
Oklahoma I want you to picture in your
head where Oklahoma is and where East
Coast is as far down as Florida and as
far up as Maine they made the natives
walk in the middle of winter they were
kicked off their land with nothing with
them it's called Trails of
tear look it
up thousands upon thousands natives pass
in that Journey
when they have them in these encampments
when they are locking them up when they
have them in these so-called
concentration camps the US government
starts giving them ra rations and the
ration was flour sugar and
lard you you come up with a better
creative idea what to do with those
three things what do you think they're
going to make and that's how fried bread
comes
out it's settler
food it's not how the Natives
eat I think there's a few Brothers I
know have you know been to China you
know I have I have friends who have
Chinese restaurant I always used to ask
him I was what do you eat and he's
not that
stuff I was is that not Chinese
food he's no we don't eat that in
China and I was wow tell me more he
said everything is sauteed or boiled I
was like
man cuz they were was not a general
named joural toe anywhere in
China this is the colon colonizer
mindset and we have just taken it and we
just drink from the same cup of the
Kool-Aid the the the oppressor wants us
to drink
from all the while Allah subh reminds us
in all who you believe
believe be steadfast on the call for
justice for the sake of Allah be a
witness to justful
Deals even if you have to go against
your own
self even if it's against your
parents and we have to understand what
the narratives are why are we being told
these things the these people are not
Savages they are not losers they are not
some you know weird folks that came
here but that's the idea I mean I could
probably ask a question please don't
raise your hand during theba you know I
will raise your you know if you could
ask a survey how many of us growing up
now I did not grow up in us and most of
you know that fairly well outside of us
I had Cowboys and Indian toy sets as
little army soldiers little little
those little green soldiers
things
what astonishing isn't
it for a kid growing up in Africa that's
what I had available to play
with that's what the stores
had they had those little Sheriff badges
and little toy belt guns and you just
put your guns and you you know walk
around you're the
sheriff that's the colonial
mindset you know even if you travel
today internationally you go someplace
and you go oh you guys don't have
McDonald's oh
man what are we missing out if we don't
have McDonald's I don't
understand you know I leave America to
go another country middle of Middle East
and it's still KFC there I'm I
didn't come here for that
brother and they always tell you like
you have to go to try to
no that's the colonizer mindset
with all due respect probably half of
the congregation more than half of the
congregation has been to
Mecca please tell me how much you how
many of you have tried the local
food no albe is not local food KFC is
not local
food party is not local food pizza is
not local food no we have no idea what
the local food
is yet we claim that we are civilized
and we are people of ethics and and
morals
and we have this going on all
along we have we have one of the for me
personally the one of the one of the
greatest presidents that I out of
out of all the presidents was Abe
Lincoln Abraham
Lincoln regardless of what you have to
say about him the man
still got rid of slavery somehow
regardless of the
facts and when I visited the the the the
memorial in Wasing Wasington I was I was
I was a little little
sentimental but under his presidency we
had the mass we had the largest hanging
of dtas the Dakota men under AB lincol
there were 38 Dakota men that were hung
publicly not only were hung publicly for
public to see they were left hanging for
several days to make a point about it
even today on the federally Tri
tribal lands there is nothing that is
there for them to to to benefit
from Brothers if we can move forward
please there's space in front of you
take the space in the back is getting
crowded and as Muslims we have to
understand the script that you see being
played out in festine the script has
been perfected in
America shrinkage of tribal lands over
time native people have no
rights they get
nothing in return from the land that we
have taken away from
them and on top of that you saw the
people marching from north of Gaza to
the south of Gaza from one place to
another place that was trailer tears
that occurred in
Americas you see that's the thing we we
have to open our eyes and Minds
understand the game has always been the
same only oppressed people have
changed we have given the natives
nothing but
obesity
diabetes heart conditions gambling and
alcoholism that's it that's all that the
the US has provided for these folks
that's
it even so so Oklahoma for couple of
years ago the Supreme Court ruled was a
tribal
land but do you think they're going to
give that state back
no somewhere along the 80s or the SE in
1700 1800s they found there was oil on
on on Indian
territory and they started extracting
oil and the natives the tribes that were
there became very very rich to a point
where they had white people as
servants what do you what do you think
would happen next the white men started
going to the area start marrying Indian
women started murdering them and
covering it up along with the with the
sheriff department locally and taking
their land
and eventually they had nothing
left this is the truth of the struggle
of the indigenous population in this
country the same as the struggle in
Canada where kids were taken away from
them under the guys were going to teach
them because they're
Savages we're going to teach them and
then they killed a mass amount of these
kids and buried them most of the kids
never returned to their parents they
were just buried in the
backyards let me ask you a
question these Savages so-called
Savages in this country you know what
their contributions are to the modern
day
Society
aspiring the most of us take
modern day aspirin was made by the
Native
Americans from willow
bark that eventually gets process into
chemical
eventually how many of us kids I still
hear Mah kids upstairs how many of them
use baby
bottles developed by the made by the
Native
Americans
lacrosse the epitome of an Ivy League
school
I'm not kidding right people people
who go to iing schools you know whose
kids are rich they play
lacrosse and then they're proud they're
oh my kid plays lacrosse you're
oh my you must have money that
thing is expensive that was developed by
the native folks show many how many
Native teams are out there playing
Lacrosse
today
none corn was in
Americas moccasin
made by the native snow shoes those big
tennis likeing looking things you
wear people wear on snows those are made
by the local folks the indigenous
population
syringes a lot of doctors here you would
not have syringes if it was not MediCal
folks they used animal Bladers and
hollow out bones to make
syringes and these are these are the the
the
uncivilized the the the UN un brute
force people right
these are the
Savages so we as Muslims have to
understand something the the the I had a
conversation with somebody last night
who was who was doing some research and
they reached out and asked me say I
can't how can I help and I said you know
history is written by the pen of the
oppressor history is always written by
the pen of the oppressor they're not
going to tell you that these were
civilized
folks even if you today Google an image
of Christopher Columbus
in getting to hispania which is the
the Caribbean islands he's shown as a
person standing up and then the natives
are under by his feet offering him
offerings why is that because eventually
they had to introduce the natives to the
people that live in the Caribbean
islands in the South America in the
North America that there is a white
jesus you have to accept the white man
as your God and savior
and that's the
narrative and we take it at face
value you know we had storms here in
Tucson a little while back and if your
house got hit you called the insurance
company and they sent you a check and
you got you get your house fixed that's
it end of the deal but if you live on
the tribal land you cannot fix your
house did you know
that there's a Department within the
federal government you have to call them
and ask their permission to fix your own
house and sometimes not months but years
go by before they approve anything if
they
do what is the idea of me me standing
here and and giving you this 25 minute
lecture on the idea is for you all and
for us all to
understand that an injustice is an
injustice regardless who it is being
committed
against it is just not one set of
people when Allah subh mentioned iny I
just
read he does not tell you oh you believe
be a witness on other Muslims no it's an
open statement to be a witness for
Justice for anybody and
anything even if it's against yourself
or your
parents and we have to understand these
issues in the
society you know I'm I'm kind of glad
that theba lands in usually a day a day
after people have celebrated
Thanksgiving because I don't want to
stand here and tell you don't celebrate
that but be be be mindful be
mindful where we're sitting at right now
in this Masid this is Theon o domination
land this is toon land and we have to
acknowledge we have to
acknowledge let me finish my first
sermon on this on this note and this is
this is a thought process for you guys
you know we see what what's happening to
our brothers and sisters in
festine even today there is a settler
Colony that PO up or a golf course that
pops up onza and a Beach property with
five star hotel pops up Ona are we going
to accept it as
theirs would
we
no as such that's the same mindset we
should have for
everybody we should pray be praying for
people around the world our brothers and
sisters in
Congo who are suffering through aarth
things they are suffering through
those regimes
so I remind you
myself that Allah
subh has not created a single living
being on this Earth without a purpose as
such we all have a purpose and just
because Allah has created us we have
respect and we have to honor each other
as Allah subhana says in the
Quran we have honored the children of
[Silence]
at
alhamdulillah ald
I want to finish with
the it is
mentioned said he heard wasam
said he said I heard wasallam said
to be
helpful to your brother whether he is
oppressor or
oppressed so asked I understand
when he's oppressed what we're supposed
to do what if he's the
oppressor wasam said by telling him that
he is the oppressor so our job is to
educate and further the
education and that only works if we have
a clean mind and a clean heart without a
bias Islam does not require a bias it
doesn't matter where you're from what
your background is you can learn if you
don't know the history you can pick up
the history book and if you don't know
learn read from a history book and come
talk to people who have done their
research on that I ask Allah subhana to
make us on the people that United hearts
and not divide Hearts we ask Allah subh
to create us from
theam in the true forms that our
Brotherhood we ask Allah subh to bless
this community first and foremost and
communities everywhere else we ask Allah
to remove all the ailments from this
community and the communities everywhere
else we ask Allah subhana tala he
has gathered us today in this Friday in
this beautiful Masjid to unite Us in the
paradise of the highest abots and I
remind you you don't see your brothers
and sisters in the paradise with you ask
Allah subh to bring them to you two
things happen if you ask Allah subh if
the brother is or sister is not there in
the Jenna Allah brings them to the Jenna
for you and if they're in the lower
parts and you're on the higher parts and
Allah brings them to you and if you're
on the lower part in their higher Parts
Allah brings them to you to you to their
are higher parts to meet them so do not
forget your brothers and sisters in the
duas may Allah subh remove all the ills
from our communities may Allah subh cure
our brothers and sisters who are
suffering through health issues may
Allah subh T make us from the true
people who stand and speak for just just
causes and stand up for brother and
sisters around the world without the
obligation or without the the the the
skewed eye view of whether they are
Muslims or
not I ask Allah to make our progy from
the of the flag barriers and the
carriers
ofam I ask Allah subh T that when he
takes us from this Earth that he is
satisfied with us and that's the only
condition takes us on and the last words
that roll off our tongue
are please move forward we have people
standing outside on
the
forar
ill inshallah we'll have a shahada after
the Salah so just be patient we'll have
a couple announcements and then we'll
take the shahada so just stay seated
please so we can we can get through the
things inshallah
faster straighten the lines fill the
gaps in between may Allah subh have
mercy upon us
alhamdulillah
[Silence]
amen
you
allahar
[Silence]
ahbar allahar
all alhamdulillah
[Silence]
amen
allar
[Silence]
allahar allb
Allah allar
hold
[Silence]
amum
my dear brothers and sisters assalamu
alaykum I have a couple of quick
announcements before we take your
attention to shahada inshallah first
reminder that we have the rahma academy
that is being funded by you with your
help and we are expanding that activity
with about 2500 square ft so some of you
may be here fresh and I would to
just remind you that this is a Saka
jaria that you can contribute
tremendously inshallah this is about
$80,000 short in completing that project
so please donate generously for that
cause and you can write a note on that
is for the new construction and
inshallah that will benefit you forever
inshallah
we also
have the rahma academy that operates
from here is using the Arizona state
taxes the taxes that you owe to the
State of Arizona we redirect it for the
benefit of the students and that is last
year we raised
$133,000 from that effort this year our
goal is for $200,000 brother jabber is
back there with a flyer and brochure so
please see him on the way out it is
tremendous importance to us we will get
the money for free because your tax
dollars will be redirected so the last
thing I want to announce is at least
mention to you we are helping purchase a
van for the daa activity it is gain
peace effort gain peace is a
organization that works throughout the
United States and it is a tremendous
organization that has helped bring in
lot of most people to the to the to the
mass and and you know reward them to
Islam so please donate for that cause if
you can
inshallah all right inshallah we have
Noah with us alongside with his family
inshallah Noah was 15 just in case you
wanted to
know can I say more things about you
no is that
okay I can I can tell you this
since we have started the Sunday School
backup
his family is probably the most
dedicated folks that I've seen in the in
the Sunday school and the parents
make sure that the kids are here along
with Mom attending the classes as well
so I ask Allah subhana T to protect the
family and reward the parents greatly
and may Allah subh make your path easier
upon walking this journey inshallah you
ready all right put your Hold Up Hold It
Up all right better all right you can
look that way if you want
[Arabic recitation]
there is no there is no deity deity
worthy worthy of worship of worship
except
except Allah Allah and I bear witness
and I bear witness that Prophet Muhammad
that Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
peace be upon Him is is his his last
last messenger messenger and servant and
servant all right give you that a hug
well I think we have a two for one so
we have one more inshallah
come on over we have one more Shah
you're ready all
right I think I thought he was going to
do it next week but here we are all
right turn around this way all
right hold it up to you chin you ready
all right
[Silence]
I bear witness I bear witness there is
no there is no deity deity worthy worthy
of worship of worship except except
Allah Allah and I bear witness and I
bear witness that that Prophet Muhammad
prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him peace
be upon Him is is his his last messenger
messenger and servant and
servant all right so I didn't I didn't
warn know know about this by the way
there's going to be about thousand
hugs coming so so embrace them
inshallah brothers and sisters I just
wanted to remind you one other the thing
that we are really thankful to have
brother Hassan as part of our
community he has been recently awarded
from Arizona Muslim
Alliance as a 2024 leader of the
year and that's our IM Hass